The experiment of sending kids back to school
during a raging hundred year pandemic by this
administration has failed and it has failed
very poorly.
And I'm not pleased to see this.
And to be clear, I wish it were possible to
send kids back to school safely right now.
It's become very popular among some on the
right to say the left wants to hurt businesses.
The left wants to hurt education.
The left wants it left, doesn't care about
people's emotional health, all because they
want to close, close, close in order to hurt
Donald Trump.
I don't deny for a second that there are tangible
benefits, intangible benefits and psychological
benefits to getting kids back to school.
I don't deny that many parents can't get back
to work unless their kids are back in school.
So I get it.
The considerations are economic.
They're emotional.
They're wide ranging.
When you have 50000 cases a day.
Fourteen hundred deaths a day.
And we've already debunked the false notion
that kids can't catch the disease or spread
the disease.
It just doesn't pass the sniff test that this
would work.
And case in point, a Georgia second grader
tested positive on day one back in school.
By day two, the classroom was closed.
The teacher and students were quarantined
for two weeks and out of school.
And there are many of these examples, 260
employees either tested positive or were exposed
in Gwinnett County public schools in Georgia.
That's Georgia's largest school district.
Hours after the first day in an Indiana district
last week, the County Health Department notified
Greenfield Central Junior High that a student
who had been in a bunch of classrooms all
over the school in contact with teachers and
students helped was helping students.
I don't remember the exact details was all
over.
The school tested positive for Corona virus.
And once again caused a mass quarantine of
14 days for everybody that they had been in
touch with.
We saw what happened in Israel where they
successfully dealt with the virus, crushed
the curve.
I mean, just obliterated it, obliterated the
curve, opens schools.
And then things went backwards very, very
quickly.
So it's not inconceivable that states could
open schools.
Some states could open schools safely, maybe.
But a lot has to happen in order to do that.
First and foremost, when we were down to 20000
cases a day.
Every state started opening.
That was not the time to actually start opening
as aggressively as happened.
Number two, I know that it's August, but we
still don't have enough testing or fast enough
testing.
The testing is falling behind the viral spread
when we talk about how much we test relative
to other countries.
Remember that at this point, circumstances
are so different in countries that in order
to keep up with our level of spread, we need
dramatically more testing and we need dramatically
faster testing.
People are often not hearing back for days,
five to seven days in some cases.
A travel blogger I know waited 20 days for
his test results, got them the day before
he was going to a different state.
This is the same issue we've been talking
about for a long time when it comes to lots
of types of businesses and organizations and
certainly schools where people are even more
crowded together for hours all day.
There is not an easy, easy answer.
I am not pretending this is simple.
I get all of the reasons why we would want
to open schools.
But what we've seen so far, we have to be
guided by the data tells me the risks exceed
the possible rewards.
By the spring semester early 2021, we might
have both more effective treatments and vaccines
that are increasingly inoculating people.
So to me, that says let's do online in the
fall.
I'm not saying don't do it.
I'm saying let's do it online.
Let's suffer through it.
My mom is a college professor.
Up until two days ago, they were planning
on allowing professors to teach in person
if they wanted to.
Now, my mom.
Already decided to go fully remote, but because
of what's happening now in Massachusetts,
which, by the way, is nothing compared to
what's going on in some states.
Her university decided we're doing all remote.
It sucks, but it makes sense.
It's a mess.
It's not political.
Masks should be worn.
It's too early to open a lot of things.
It's not political.
I'm so glad I'm not in a position of having
to send kids to school or not and make decisions
about where they should be.
I don't envy the parents.
I don't envy the teachers or the administrators.
I'm not pretending it's easy.
I get it.
There is not a simple answer, but it's increasingly
clear that the safe answer is you've got to
do online in the fall.
And increasingly, it seems more and more states
are going in that direction.
Let me know what's happening in your state.
Let me know on Twitter at David Pakman.
And remember, you can listen to the David
Pakman show podcast every day, every weekday,
OK?
We take weekends off on whatever your favorite
podcasting app is, Spotify, I, iTunes, Stitcher,
Pandora.
It's quite a laundry list.
It's almost too easy to get the audio podcast,
but I encourage you to do it.